today's question comes from sean in
north dakota he writes in my wife and i
have become a great team when it comes
to do-it-yourself
and construction projects she's a
realtor and i can do just about anything
construction related
we have flipped one house for ourselves
which is paid off and it is now being
rented
we have also done flips and remodels on
about 10 other homes for
other people all have made a pretty
decent return that we could live on
if we did it full time my question is i
currently have a job which pays okay but
i
absolutely hate it we were thinking
about selling our rental
and our current home and start buying
houses to live in and flip as we go
while also
still doing realty work for other people
is this a solid plan
i think it's pretty close to solid i
would just caution you that
do you have to go all in on selling your
current home selling the rental to get
you that capital because it is paid off
to get the capital to get started uh not
a bad idea
the other thing that i'd throw out there
dave to sean is that uh
what if they keep that cash home that
they are making rental income off of
and he starts working for his wife when
she's got houses you know she's listing
and selling
and inevitably when people sell a home
you get that inspection report you gotta
do some work
what if he becomes her guy that comes in
and fixes these homes up i think that's
a way to juice his income
but i think they've got a really good
plan and i would tell him start moving
forward on this because he hates his job
uh he can do the construction projects
they're both in the same business
together i love this i think it's a
great move start moving forward today
i completely agree the warning is the
same thing i
i probably would not sell my personal
home i probably sell the rental and no
debt that's right
zero don't get so fired up about this
that you start you look up you got 10
houses you own and you're in debt a
million dollars don't do this
that's how people go bankrupt in that
world and they do it all the time
i will tell you this someone who knows
how to do home repairs
basic remodeling or even extensive
remodeling
can if you just show up on time do the
work on time
and do high quality work you will always
have more work than you can do
a friend of mine runs a one person
operation he made three hundred thousand
profit on last year
now he's subbing out yep that's gonna
work but he's basically g
seeing it and he's doing some of the
smaller jobs by with his own hands
but he made 300 grand yeah and he's
running around with a
you know a pickup full of tools and he
can do anything like this guy
you can build a deck he can replace a
dishwasher i mean he he can
paint a room and if it's a bigger job he
gets a painter yeah if it's a bigger job
he gets a carpenter
right but uh and subs that out but he
doesn't have any employees
he's his own boss and you can do that
for yourself you can do that for others
and your wife can be a feeder for you on
it as she's doing other real estate
deals for clients and they need
something help
like like ken mentioned with this uh the
inspection reports go sideways on you or
something on them and you can just step
in be the hero
yeah i i'm doing this starting tomorrow
well if he called into the show i would
ask and i'd say how much you're
currently making because one other thing
i just add to that is
if i know that it's a short term like
six months a year
before i leave this job that i hate but
i need that income still
uh i can change my mindset and i can
start doing all these things on the side
and you're working hard on saturdays and
friday nights and you can come in and
fix a kitchen at night
so you could do a side hustle and then
build that as you dave as you teach us
this idea of
let's get that boat closer to the dock
so he's got a lot of options here but
the idea is
move forward yeah definitely got to do
it at the end of the year you need to be
doing this for sure
at the end of next year 12 months from
today you need to be going on